that's not a fair trade because now
Magnus has passed pawns on either side
of the board and it's completely winning
okay with one point it's always sticky
the Jewish margins are enormous even
sometimes the computer says it's a draw
but practically speaking it's still very
difficult oh however there it is
Queen C4 check and the handshake
wow what a fight
incredible A fitting conclusion to
a struggle between two Gladiators and
Vincent kymer will feel pain
he came oh so close in the classical
portion
he recovered from one lost position
after another
in the rapid portion he brought this
down to the wire even this game down to
a Time scramble down to a tactical
affair